happy Monday reject nation how you doing
G Alba here j-train here speaking of JJ
pill one Hall J and the G Jake
Gyllenhaal's in the news today because
he is gonna be playing supposedly and
Mysterio Quentin Beck supposedly for the
spider-man homecoming sequel and I think
Jake Gyllenhaal in terms of performance
is perfect for this guy
I kind of was hoping that if they were
ever to bring Mysterio to the big screen
because I grew up watching this
spider-man animated series quoting
Beck's not a very attractive looking
dude and Jake Gyllenhaal is a pretty
attractive guy although I think what a
lot my mom assuming a lot of people are
gonna be going back to is remember him
and I crawler though he's like really
creepy yeah nowadays he's willing to
like immerse himself and yeah alter his
physical appearance and hide yeah ugh I
mean it's all in the way he comes across
I can make him seem kind of creepy I
feel like he would be good for that I
mean I like this character a lot he's
always I think because growing up in LA
he was a character I was always very
drawn to the guy was like a visual
effects guy and he was also sup man I
believe the way how the story goes with
him TV also try becoming an actor he
wasn't able to make his way into
Hollywood eventually he got into like
the the theatrics so he decided to frame
spider-man spider-man even started
thinking he was going crazy he was able
to create it as the costume and the webs
like creat designs to make it look like
spider-man was committing crime sermon
Peter Parker was like thinking he's
actually nuts eventually you know
Spiderman was able to take the guy down
guy went to jail and I believed to then
Mysterio does become a part of the
sinister six which includes like Doc Ock
I believe vultures in the sinister six
knowing that this movie is also in
Sony's hands as well I'm wondering if
they are trying to segue into sinister
six again yeah they wanted to it the
amazing series and I bet they want to
now they have like several villains
already established Michael Keaton's
already confirmed to return for a
spider-man homecoming - and they even
tease like scorpion and they'll says
shocker in there vulture and scorpion
are in prison together I guess the big
word
that can come into this is that it could
go in a sequel overload again definitely
see that especially with the spider-man
movies I wonder if Sony is trying to
pick up the mantle for WB after Suicide
Squad crash because it seems like right
now they're leading with venom they've
got this new big villain and Sony's
gonna distribute Home Coming to so that
yeah makes me wonder all kinds of things
about what their plans are I think Jake
Gyllenhaal though would be awesome to
have in the movie some people are saying
he's confirmed some people are saying
he's just in talks for the movie Jake
Gyllenhaal is that other Leo where you
were like has this dude won an Oscar yet
and in some ways I think some people
would s say that Jake Gyllenhaal might
be even more talented in terms of range
then someone like a leader hardik Caprio
as far as Jake Gyllenhaal remember at
one point was it was in talks to play
spider-man in the rainy cereal and halls
so much sexier and Tobey Maguire's so
much dirtier yeah that's a bigger
Gyllenhaal I could be sexy or three me
yeah but is either of those right yeah
yeah I would have cast him as Harry baby
this kind of villain is the type of
villain I'm always been drawn to because
of the fact that how his career was
based out in filmmaking doing stunts
doing visual effects this guy also has
like hypnotic abilities I'm wondering
how they're gonna tone this character
down because a lot of times you watch
the cartoons or you read the comics
these characters are really like loud
and spouting evil things haha yeah I
kind of don't hope they do that for
Mysterio Jake jong-il is perfect for
that kind of delivery and also knowing
what they did with the vulture costume
in spider-man homecoming one yeah that
does make me wonder are they gonna bring
the fishbowl head cape and the green of
the year that could look silly in a
movie they like decided to update it
inspire my homecoming one where it's
like really high tech and he's got the
cool mask and everything so maybe
they'll do some modern-day update on it
so that make the fishbowl head look cool
or they'll like give some kind of
explanation that like it really gives
him these powers somehow and here's this
yeah yeah I think it would be neat if it
was kind of like a step one suit you
know kind of how like Sue's body has
like that oh cool yeah hoody suit I
think it'd be fun if he had this like
kind of cheesy looking step once
yoshino well this would be the first
time that we've seen Mysterio like live
action on screen right yeah like that's
actually exciting to me because in a
time where we have you know so many
characters being realized and being put
up it's like weird to think like oh yeah
we've not seen Mysterio yet and
especially with how strong the villain
was in homecoming and then kind of
helping to set that movie apart this
actually makes me look that much more
forward to homecoming to you know
especially because Jake Johan and then
Tom Holland playing off each other I can
only imagine is probably gonna be pretty
fun I feel like if you potentially go
down some minor green goblin territory
from the first spider-man movie because
of the type of villain Mysterio is and
also I believe he was setting up to
frame spider-man because he wanted to
unveil himself as a hero make himself of
a good guy I remember Mysterio was
inspired by The Daily Bugle and there's
even some meeting he has with the Daily
Bugle before spider-man catches him I
don't think though the Daily Bugle will
be involved in this so they're gonna
have to tweak some hordes and stuff it's
not the biggest part of Mysterio's
origins but I think it would be neat to
at least include the Daily Bugle and
doing reports on how spider-man is not
really a good hero but yet you don't
have to go and see the behind the scenes
at the Daily Bugle you don't have to go
and see Jay jonah Jameson you could
still keep Peter Parker in high school
and still have all that you can just
have a whisper happening yeah you can
just have the recurring motif of the
headlines getting worse and worse and
worse and have the bugle not so much an
intimate place that we know about right
now for especially you know spider-man's
not working there at all yet yeah you
know you just have it be this force
that's kind of appropriate for now too
when the news being as tenuous as it is
for people if I were to make a
prediction on this with vultures still
being back and if they're not gonna do
villain overload I would imagine that
Mysterio probably goes to jail early on
in the film maybe midpoint or beginning
of act 2 somehow vulture does reveal to
Mysterio who spider-man really is and
then Mysterio starts to using that
against spider-man like that that's how
I imagine they'd use him especially
because they have confirmed Michael
Keaton's coming back I don't know I mean
this this is still excited to me cuz
Gyllenhaal is one of my favorite actors
around right now yeah so this this is
still really cool news and I'm excited
for it man
alright guys well what do you think
about Jake Gyllenhaal being cast as
Mysterio do you wish they got Steve
Buscemi and
step oh you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Belka subscribe buttons don't really
work check us out on patreon full-length
TV show reactions music video coverage
weekly Q&A is a whole bunch of goodies
offered over there ever love to have you
become a patreon object to die please